teaching of Valley's most accurate
forecast on 8 news now wow that is
awesome okay hey we're going to start
with California where that atmospheric
River we've been talking about is still
pounding our neighbors to the West in
San Francisco they're talking about
maybe an additional five more inches of
rain on top of everything that they've
already had including Gusty winds
knocking over trees and taking out power
lines now we head back home and check
out things at Lee Canyon this is a live
picture from the webcam up there and
everybody is having a grand old time now
Transportation getting to and from the
mountain may get trickier as we get
through the afternoon and certainly over
the next 24 hours so again mom Nature's
bark looking a little worse than the
bite here in town great view though from
our camera way down in the Southeast
this is at Sunset Station looking across
at the strip and it's definitely wanting
to rain we've had a couple of sprinkles
53 the official temperature out at Reed
International clinging to the 40s along
the western side of town humidity is up
there it feels brisk outside even though
these temperatures are not too far away
from normal for this time of year but
you had that humidity in let's check in
with our family and friends with the
Nevada and Beyond Death Valley only in
the mid 50s right now much more snow for
Reno Tonopah and Caliente up in Lincoln
County and certainly Cedar City as well
now we're going to try for 59 if we get
that far today that would be above
normal but with the cloud cover it's
maybe looking a little bit iffy let's
take you through the next several hours
so in the next half hour it looks like
the rain is just going to continue to
kind of dance around us while dumping
rain and snow up over the higher
elevations by this evening and certainly
by eight it's going to look trickier but
then it rolls on through until we get to
tomorrow morning that's a much better
shot at rain and even better by tomorrow
afternoon we're talking about maybe
upwards of a quarter of an inch of rain
meantime we go to the actual radar and
that's exactly what we're keeping an eye
on that atmospheric River more impact to
our neighbors to the West for your
family and friends a fairly quiet day
but as this storm system tracks to the
east it will definitely bear watching
all right here's your most accurate
eight day forecast winds gusting to 40
miles an hour tonight and tomorrow again
that wind advisory tomorrow we get a
break for a couple of days Wednesday and
Thursday before more clouds and the next
system brings chances for rain Saturday
and Sunday Ted florendo takes you
through the afternoon with the radar
wash Heather